good evening everyone I'm Laura Ingram
this is Ingram angle from Washington
tonight cleaning up for the boss that's
the focus of tonight's
Angle now for years elected Democrats in
San Francisco and Democrat Governors
have said that fixing the homelessness
and crime problem was complex and it
would take more money and a lot of
patience police officials told the angle
they felt
helpless you get to stay out here and do
as much just live out here do as much
drugs as
cuz uh the injunction about clearing
tents and homeless en Camp camps so you
can't clear it out can't do that no
right but they want us to do they want
us to but we can't do it by law right a
judge says no unless you can provide a
bed for every person you see out
president's complaints about the crime
public fental use and general filth fell
on deaf ears but it turns out a court
order wasn't a problem at all all they
needed was a visit by the guy who really
has influence Chinese president xiin pin
while San Francisco is in the spotlight
for the asia-pacific economic conference
city leaders are making sure the city
shines calr repaving major roadways like
the Harrison Street off-ramp from the
I80 Bart doubling down by deep cleaning
their stations overnight more often
scrubbing and power washing is happening
all over the city yeah the bottom my
shoes look clean like it's noticeable
how clear the streets look and how few
homeless encampments there are on major
thorough Affairs now this shows us what
total frauds these political leaders are
because they always had the ability to
clean up the cities and clean out the
drug dens to send a strong message to
criminals but they chose not to some
people say this should be how it's
always done what about the people who
are here year round you know in like
local hardworking working class Bay Area
folks the answer the left cares about
power not about your quality of life
they let the city sink into depra
gravityy because changing policies would
mean they'd be admitting that their High
tax anti- police pro-criminal Pro drugs
policies were wrong but now they're kind
of like teenage girls primping before a
date new some pitting up things for
someone he needs to impress I know folks
say oh they're just cleaning up this
place cuz all those fancy leaders are
coming into town um that's
true because it's
true but it's also true for months and
months and months prior to Apec we've
been having different
conversations and we've raised the bar
of expectation between the city the
county than the state oh we couldn't do
that before but we just we're so happy
to do it now this is more meaningless
bla from him the truth is Nome actually
cares about what XI thinks because
remember he's going to need Tik Tock
influencers to boost his future
political Ambitions and he's going to
need the pro-china donors from hedge
funds and and Silicon Valley on his side
as well this requires making X's date
feel very special and ditto for the
Biden Campaign which is hoping to win
over China to reassure Wall Street and
to get their concrete pledges on climate
change now the entire purpose of this
meeting with China is to get a smiling
photo op and to signal to the money
class here that we want a new era of
collaboration with China now how do you
think Taiwan is feeling these days
and just as San Francisco Democrats have
tried to paper over the suffering and
the blight that they incentivized so too
have the Liberals in DC if you've been
here lately tent cities are growing and
so is open a drug use the place has
spiraled into a sea of violence and
criminality especially carjackings and
car
break-ins a 15 and 16-year-old are
facing a number of charges connected to
a string of armed carjackings when it
comes to carjacking and stuff like that
it happens so much it's sad DC is under
siege and uh we need
help so hearing all this why was anyone
surprised by this
story Secret Service is saying that just
before midnight last night in the
Georgetown neighborhood of Washington DC
uh right outside Naomi Biden's apartment
building that's one of the
granddaughters of President Biden uh
that secret service encountered what
they believe were three people breaking
a window of a parked unmarked and
unoccupied government vehicle they say
an agent discharged their service weapon
Secret Service says that the offenders
immediately fled the scene in a red
vehicle now the first thing that crossed
my mind was what would have happened had
a regular citizen shot at those
criminals well we know what would happen
he'd be in jail right now was the Biden
granddaughter's life actually in danger
well that is what the Secret Service is
saying glad everyone is okay the sad
reality is this just as we saw with the
migrant Shi to Martha's Vineyard and of
course to Manhattan the elites are often
able to ignore the problems that the
rest of the America deals with but when
they arrive on their doorstep oh they're
suddenly forced to answer questions or
deal with the
consequences and even if the answers
they give are pathetic the president has
taken action to make sure our
communities are are safer are we
concerned obviously obviously we want to
make sure Americans and their families
feel safe in not just here in DC but
across communities but we can't do this
alone we need Congress to act okay if
the voters are okay with those types of
foolish answers then they're going to
continue to get bad results so let's
hope from coast to coast The Awakening
has begun and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else